en ces temps de confinement nous sommes
sûrement très nombreux à ouvrir ce genre
de petites boîtes pour déguster celles
qui sont confinés à l'intérieur depuis
parfois plusieurs années
l'invention de la boîte de conserve a
révolutionné l'alimentation elle permet
de conserver les aliments pendant très
longtemps c'est un français qui a mis la
technique aux points
nicolas appert en 1795 la technique
consiste à chauffer les aliments à 100°
au bain-marie pour décrire les bactéries
des aliments que l'on a placé au
préalable dans une boîte étanche pour
éviter d'être contaminée à nouveau les
petits poissons les premiers légumes
avoir été mis en conserve
vous allez comprendre pourquoi à
l'origine la boîte n'était pas
métallique elle était envers nicolas
appert utilisaient des bouteilles de
champagne
et oui et les seuls à pouvoir résister à
la pression liée à la dilatation de
l'air à l'intérieur au moment du
chauffage alors évidemment avec des
sardines c'est beaucoup moins facile à
remplir la boîte de sardine a quant à
elle été inventé en 1823 par un certain
monsieur colin sardines colin ça ne
s'invente pas quant à cette capsule de
les confiner bien je vous conseille de
la consommer fraîches
si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez également voir ou revoir les
vidéos des jours précédents en cliquant
sur le côté gauche en réalise une
nouvelle chaque jour et pendant loupé
qu'une et bien abonnez vous et activer
la petite cloche alia demain
et n'oubliez pas nous sommes confinés
mais en restant lien